to keep Europe's economy flourishing and
abreast with internal and global
challenges of the future mobility is key
business settles where it finds
efficient connections with partners
clients and labor citizens consumer
choices are vitally influenced by the
availability and quality of transport
services transport services for
companies and people can only expand
with a highly efficient infrastructure
basis
the blueprint for a new strong European
infrastructure basis has been in place
since 2013 now it is time to put the
blueprint into practice many challenges
will have to be met such as the
completion of the full-scale network
with railway lines roads inland
waterways ports airports and equipment
to enable intelligent and clean services
this implies around 700 billion euro of
private and public investment
work on completion of the core network
until 2030 will generate a GDP increase
of 1.8% this means around 10 million man
years of employment in the 15 years
ahead in the construction industry as
well as other sectors which benefit from
enhanced accessibility and continuing
benefits for growth and jobs after 2030
enabling high standard services for
business and people
to achieve this powerful EU Instruments
must be used such as a budget of 24
billion euro of grants and innovative
financial instruments until 2020 a key
role will be played by nine core network
corridors as well as two horizontal
priorities by rail with the er TMS and
by sea with motorways of the sea which
will allow the gathering of more than
2,500 projects to meet the enormous
financial challenges private financing
needs to be mobilized
10t projects presents a significant
potential to contribute to such
investments and may benefit for this
purpose from the European Fund for
strategic investment their
implementation will be facilitated by
eleven European coordinators Member
States regions and other public and
private investors can also help
achieving these objectives by cleaning
ownership and commitment because
mobility is key we dedicate our time to
connecting Europe
you
you